this podcast is brought to you by on it
for your supplemental needs on it will
fill that boy go Dinah calm right now
and press in church and get 10% off
delivered this podcast is also brought
to you by MBM t watches let me explain
something to you mbm t watches start at
just $95 at the department store you're
looking at 400 to 500 bucks over 1
million watches have been sold in over
160 countries I'll tell you what I'm
going to do go to M V MP watches and get
15% off today when you go to MB MT
watches dot-com / Church CH you are CH
this podcast is also brought to you by
blue apron as far as home delivery foods
concerned blue apron is the king go to
blue apron calm right now / Joey get
three first meals free on the arm go to
blue apron calm / joy right now and get
your first three meals free with free
shipping what's happening to bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey here my main
man Lisa at the reason why we're doing
this podcast is an unusual podcast this
is the way we start at the first podcast
but after right Azizi came on the show a
couple of months ago he had a brilliant
idea where he goes over books or
whatever and when we first started the
podcast we used to talk about a lot of
different books and whatnot and it was
one [ __ ] topic that's always killed me
and it's the Iceman as you guys know
yeah he was from Jersey and the whole
thing but let's start from the beginning
I've always been a read I've been a
reader since mr. King will left me back
in the seventh grade and I just like to
read I'm an only child and I've always
read I can't read everything there's a
lot of stuff that I read for pages and I
got to get rid of it
that you know if I got ten books in one
day I would read three of those ten
books because those other seven are just
written you know sometimes the two the
divider thinks he's to swarmy or
sometimes they talk too much about the
same subject like I got a book about
Rudy Tomjanovich about when he got
[ __ ] beat up at the Laker game by
kind of Washington it was a good book it
was very informative but myself is very
repetitive you know and then you might
read a book that s like a movie done
around it and the movie is always better
in the book where the books always
better the movie then you know I read
sound to the Lambs and it's just as good
as the [ __ ] movies just you just have
to read you know and see what you like
how how long do you give about like how
much would you give give you like a
chapter what are your four chapters and
I could tell this is going in the
direction that this is not going to go
in its anything else in life if you try
everything on the menu there's things
you're not gonna like that's the problem
with books that I think it's so
important to [ __ ] read I think it's
so important if I can read that no
matter what you do I mean your wife has
realized she has to read you know it's
so important to give especially when you
write the only way you could learn how
to write is to complement it by reading
and reading different types of authors
like I said yet listen man some people
pick up [ __ ] Hemingway and think it's
junk some people pick up the Koski and
think it's junk you know but everybody
has their own style of whatever I don't
like subjects about the moon I don't
like a lot of subjects that a lot of
people would think I like I like
subjects about stories about characters
or like characters I like to read about
the psychology of that [ __ ] character
what made him do these things
what do you mean characters anything you
really you love interesting people it
seems like wow I can't stay a [ __ ]
boring people who do you think I want to
sit there next to somebody tell me but
you know the same [ __ ] everybody else is
telling me you know I'm not normal I'm
not like everybody else and I know this
going in that's what makes this podcast
successful at the people listened to the
podcast we're all missing a [ __ ] nut
somewhere so I'm not normal but I know
this going in right I talk to people I
know they look at me weed or whatever my
views or whatever and the same thing
happens to books you know you're not
going to give everybody people send me
books all the time and some books I've
read a few chapters and they're [ __ ]
god-awful is not me
do you have a thing with like for me
happens with movies where someone like
really is excited about a movie or a
book and they sell it to you and then by
the time you read it you're like oh this
is garbage like this like oh that
happens over
obviously about different tastes so they
don't know I'm into more criminal stuff
meant to be I'm a criminal I always want
to delve into the mind of the criminal
how we wanted to see what made me do the
things I did at the different time
periods of my life I'm 50 when I was 20
and we got into an argument that was
always a misunderstanding I might
[ __ ] shoot you I didn't know what
when I did that kidnapping my state of
mind was completely different I'm not
the same person who was today so always
one of the study what had made me come
to those conclusions what made me kidnap
well maybe pull a John a knife on John
what made me do all those robberies when
I was a kid know those stupid [ __ ]
burglaries has amounted to nothing it
was a state of mind I was in you know so
I always want to see what people stay
the minds are and I've always been a
student of the mind of watching people
have you ever have you read a book or or
and well just seems fake like because
you you're a criminal look everywhere a
book about a criminal in yourself yeah I
could tell when it's a book about a
criminal or a book about somebody a
nostalgic about something it's two
different things okay there's two books
about the Iceman there's the one that uh
Brunel wrote Anthony Brunelli one we're
going to discuss today which focuses
more on the investigation okay and
there's one other guy Carlo wrote that
that was the one that they auctioned at
first for Mickey Rourke for this movie
about the Iceman the carlo book tells
you all i thinkt up by the time i don't
know which one of these books came first
but by the time the carlo book came it
was what happened on his HBO specials he
just got a glamorizing it and he just
doesn't get you know he was responsible
for JFK he was there when they killed
that guy joe mary's he was yet at
towards the end he was saying that he
was there when they shot Paul Castellano
you know he just started so he I think
the others the other book he talked
about more hits that we had never heard
about and now I'm starting to wonder
about those hits a lot of them this book
the one we're gonna discuss today we're
gonna have uh Dominick call up today all
right this guy's name is Dominick krola
phone and he was the undercover cop for
the ATF that worked closely with Essex
County
to take down the Iceman I am the cover
name was Dominic Michael provenzano you
know he kept it the same and we're going
to ask him what undercover questions I
mean you know is it true like I always
thought like when I lived in Boulder the
cops that undercover cops that worked in
Boulder that came from Boulder usually
arrested people at Aspen they were sent
to Aspen so nobody would know them how
far apart of those two hours okay cuz
here's one of the things I'm gonna ask
him that just he talked about he was
from Jersey and he had broadly he would
like he grew up in the area I don't like
that doesn't seem far enough apart from
exactly I mean it seems like it would be
it like I don't know like home goods or
a store and just like it pumping lemma
yeah yeah yeah that's it like and he did
it's not it sounds like he did a bunch
of them like he was I read some things
in he talks about like the process he
went through I'm very into like it
sounds like he was like almost kind of
like his own boss I watched too many
movies you have to be if you read this
book you realize what I've been telling
you people for the last 20 years I'm
gonna ask them right in front of you
people that for every a 100 kilo million
dollar arrest you see on TV they bloom
nine of them they blow nine of them they
blow nine of them because once you get
all the bureaucracy involved and all
these white dudes who think they know
what they're talking about that's what
they blow the case because a part in
this book who would discuss with
Dominick where he's getting ready he's
in with the Iceman he's then he's in
with him but now they want to send
another guy in with him to learn to make
an introduction this guy's a
professional if I'm doing business with
Lee one on one every day Lee comes to me
and bring me guns and one day don't
serie for four days he comes back to
meet me he shows up with somebody
I guess into that I keep my answers very
[ __ ] loose and I get my car and I go
home and I got to assume that's a
professional at that time undercover cop
see this is what I'm fascinated by is
that's what I would imagine especially
on the Iceman's level that he'd be way
more way more cautious way more course
and then one time like apparently like
they wanted to get as ice man for the
murders so Dominic was talking about how
he like he had him talk about each one
of the murders on a recording and I'm
just thinking like how is this guy
bringing a brand of murders and how does
that not enough bells well do you know
before you it's like going for the [ __ ]
before you kiss it titties but you don't
kiss her neck and her titties and you
just go right for the [ __ ] Allah Trump
it's not going to get you this is a
process if you come over overzealous as
an undercover agent take on a smithy and
if you don't look at people's eyes and
you I mean there's so many [ __ ]
things that I used to read as a criminal
like I once read I once heard from one
of my friends and somebody brings one of
those people put a blue suit on them if
they look like a cop they're a [ __ ]
cop so you know I never ever ever and
all those stories I'm telling you guys
for [ __ ] 10 years of all the [ __ ]
I put up with I've never really had too
many contacts with cops because I smelt
them I I know exactly when somebody
shows up with a cop even when I was a
young kid that was a really interesting
story when I first met North Bergen in
83 about a guy who was coming to the bar
bringing us all back to his house and
taking our drugs in front of us and
jewelry I knew that guy was a cop huh I
knew that guy was a cop the second time
I went to his [ __ ] house I put it
together how many times you go to the
help that's it I think God okay alright
like that I just seen that's it I didn't
want to be on camera I didn't want to be
bringing people like wouldn't leave that
area would you go like god I stayed for
a few we don't know I went over the
second time I just thought about it
sound too easy even at the age of 19 I
knew if it sounded too easy it was too
[ __ ] easy so you're inviting 10
strangers from a bar to your house and
you're taking out pieces of gold and
half ounces of blow and she's showing
all this jewelry you're looking for
something don't get me wrong and my 20
years of [ __ ] doing all that [ __ ] I
bumped into a lot of stupid [ __ ]
people I bumped into a lot of stupid
people that had no idea who they were
dealing with when they taken our jewelry
at 2:00 in the morning and showing
people you know
guns they have you just set yourself up
for somebody to rob me so it was just
yours I'm going to take you down please
get your inner feeling your gut feeling
that separating them between two easy
and a comp too easy
ah too easy there's got to be a little
bit resistance somewhere that this is
too easy you bring me to your house you
show me you're safe you show me your
bedroom you show me your jewelry you're
turning me on to coke you're dropping
names like it's going out of style
something's not [ __ ] right here yeah
is it and they're like how did you ever
did you hear someone not following that
guy like that seems like way all the
time listen I read this book The Iceman
did not get caught because the cops are
that good The Iceman got caught because
as you get older you get tired and as
the more you do something you get
repetitive and no matter how careful you
could be he was leaving you get sloppy
you could be tight for six years not
everybody could be perfect on you
[ __ ] percent so we're all gonna make
mistakes along the line cops
detectives investigators they pray for
that one mistake that's all they pray
for kuklinski Bennett with Dominic he
got so much trust under Dominic he was
he had killed Braun gay by that time he
needed cyanide to kill people he had to
go out in the open he had to go on the
stomach that's what that expression is
called going out on your stomach you
know a lot of people don't like selling
drugs there's a lot of money in drugs
you know what happens when you sell
drugs you gotta go on your stomach you
got exposed yourself so once you a lot
of people do great unless they have to
expose themselves and it seems like he
really at least at the beginning made a
really big effort to not expose no
revenue a regular family line a great
the way he was doing things the hits he
was selling weapons you know he kept it
to a minimum he dealt with it's a lot
the more moving parts the more chances
of you getting popped and then I know
he's in a costume but as another
criminal and you see someone like this
and all of his associates are getting
killed all the Iseman associates are
getting murdered why why are people
still working with him
like that just seems crazy to me why do
people still smoke cigarettes come on up
you can find a McDonalds why do people
still do cocaine why do people still buy
[ __ ] shitty records and go to [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's the same reason we all have
weak points in our lives you know when I
kidnapped a fella that was a very weak
point for me why because I wouldn't be
caught dead talking to those guys I got
in trouble with nothing million years
would I be caught dead talking to those
[ __ ] idiot but I got desperate
I like the junk gave me take over I
wanted to believe that Tidwell was the
real deal even though I knew he was a
[ __ ] joke that's the headline now you
wanted to believe I wanted to believe he
said he was the real deal with the
motorcycles and the taxes and the pit
bulls and the tinted windows in the loud
stereo and the strip clubs and all that
[ __ ] all his [ __ ] stupid about his
partners will have some partners that
were doing time which gives a [ __ ] I
really wanted to believe that that was
all fake but I knew deep in my gut it
was all fake and then when I got
sentence and I saw him mopping he was a
trustee with a [ __ ] on parole with a
violent crime and you're a felon you got
to be a rat to have that [ __ ] job but
that's the mistakes we all make we all
listen I was given dabbling since I was
14 15 right some mountain by mescaline
so an acid that all counts
sewed all this [ __ ] you do you know you
always asked me how did you get away
with loans because I did it with people
I helped with I grew up with you know I
had six or seven customers that's it one
somebody comes to you and go hey I got a
gun at once of my 10,000 hits once a
week sounds too good sounds too easy
just like that he's going to give me
[ __ ] I mean if you read this book at
the end with Dominic he wanted Sinai he
was going to sell Dominic a half a
million dollars what the weapons and
trying to shoot him and and he was gonna
[ __ ] kidnap and drug Jewish kid that
wanted to buy three kilos all in one day
by himself no with that so
he was gonna meet Dominic Dominic was
going to bring the Jewish kid they were
gonna spray cyanide in his hamburger and
then [ __ ] kill him and then get split
to $85,000 for the three kilos and
Dominic would've had him on murder
that's the last thing Dominic was trying
to set him up with cyanide for him to
put on his hamburger rented and there on
top of that he was going to set up a
deal for Dominic to buy silences on the
38 on 22s to sell to the Irish Republic
and when he shown up at the half a
million dollars he was going to kill
Dominic Integris apically now Oh golly I
hate uncle Dominic right yelling I want
your buddy thank you very much for
taking the time to call on the line I
got special retired agent one of my new
uncle's Dominic Pro the phone I've been
a fan of yours for 20 years you know I
saw you on the HBO documentaries and
stuff and I was talking about the book
one day the other shitty book the the
Carlo book and a mutual friend of ours
connected us together this is one of my
this is one of my best days ever in
podcasting because we get to read a book
and we get to talk to a real deal how
you doing today sir
I'm doing good yeah especially when I
speak with you oh my god it's been we
were talking all week you told me to
read this Iceman by Anthony Bruno I pass
it on to my partner Lili say hello - hi
mr. provolone hello mr. Brooklyn Pro
laughs oh no I'm sorry
and we're both sitting here in shock you
know I read this book thinking about the
Iceman but I ended up learning about a
[ __ ] cop from New Jersey that has
balls of steel and I also ended up
learning about myself where I got the
craziness I have installed in me and
it's somewhere in that water in northern
New Jersey brother okay you one thing
I'm surprised I'll catch didn't cross
you know I was right there from 80 or 85
like I told you this morning in the book
they mentioned you kept meeting him at
the Vince Lombardi truck stop and pour
or again in New Jersey are the only
states that you could you can't pump
your own gas when you go to Oregon
there's a pumper and when there's when
you go to New Jersey there's always a
guy gas station attendant I got a job
once I was telling you this morning at
the vince lombardi and it was going to
raining out dominic and i got the shift
from 4:00 to 12:00 and I would get the
shift and they would tell me to drop
every time I would all I would always
get jobs at gas stations that were close
to the bridge or the tunnel so when they
would be busy and I would come up with
like two three thousand dollars and I
have a friend pick me up on the corner
and that was the only time ever I ever
got caught I almost got caught was at
vince lombardi because the guy chasing
but then I lost him because I got on the
bus it's not there's no easy way to get
get adalat oh my god oh my god I got on
the bus and then he called the cops and
the bus took off and I'm [ __ ]
sweating bullets I get to Port Authority
I'm thinking a concert gonna be there
was a long cop dad got away with it but
yeah yes all pads could have crossed at
one time or another how long were you a
cop for dominic um close to thirty years
I started let the Bergen County
Prosecutor's Office and then I wanted to
see what the government was about and I
looked and I really liked ATF Alcohol
Tobacco and Firearms Street agency you
know and that's fits my type of mold
sort of and I wanted to see really what
the difference is when they the truth
the difference between the state and
federal is more [ __ ] on the federal
level but yet more lead way where
there's always more bureaucracy and more
paperwork when you're dealing with the
feds they're [ __ ] Gentiles you got to
do a pinata for you shoot somebody yet
somebody pulls a gun they shoot at you
you shoot them back to get them in the
leg you got 19 pages you got to write a
[ __ ] encyclopedia why you shot them
what color the Sun was it's ridiculous I
got a lot of paperwork they talk about
paper reduction Act and all this bunch
of [ __ ] Oh Dominic I was I was
watching something when you were
speaking about the process
that you would go through as an
undercover just going from the different
agencies and like just to get like the
approval to do it like to me it seemed
like I don't know someone would just
give you an assignment need going like a
team like you will really want like you
were going and dealing with all this
bureaucracy yourself as like almost like
a solo practice like it was weird like
you almost weren't being governed at all
no it's true
well we'll just particular case those
richard kuklinski you know I just got
done finishing the case Beyonce
infiltrated roll flight an agenda New
York and we took down I know around 68
people and a lot of made guys and then
there was a contract out on me and they
wanted to send me somewhere else but
ironically you some of the processes I
was fortunate enough to stay in this
area and I chose Jason I said that's was
born and raised and that's why I want to
go and they thought it was crazy but
that's what they gave me and that's my
career and I was watching enough to work
the New York New Jersey area I mean I
did a little of you know doing
undercover st. croix Porto Rico Miami
Denver Washington just a bunch of places
I almost work for different agencies
getting things on consignment which was
unheard of and you know built a
reputation I was fortunate enough I
really learned a lot from one of my
partners Alex Dee actually born in
Brooklyn New York
and we were very close to this date he's
lucky he's alive he was shot by clients
in Miami in a deal land with a 357 and
the other agent was shot in the head
died and he's fortunate enough to live
we're still in communication and learned
a lot learned a lot learn what works
wanted to come on strong on the back off
and you know you get that gut feeling
get on weapons somebody is in the
streets so I was fortunate enough
I spent about over 15 years in the
streets you know really made mistakes as
a neophyte book but down a road and I
had an individual and that went on the
witness protection program sat me down
we hit it off and I worked with him for
quite some long some time long time
matter of fact so you had an acting
coach you know the nice thing really
really made my bones that you had an
acting coach I had an acting coach the
only thing with that is once you make
the introduction I don't believe you
know a source continuing to work I get
him out of the picture and then I woke
up the alphabet and I feel that after my
experience and everything they're not
bragging or anything like that that you
know I was good enough to have a career
they should say what does that woke them
he tightened up on you but I was real
fortunate enough that nothing that
happened and to this day even with the
wiseguys I made you know I mean we might
have broke bread here and there but that
was basically doing it they respected me
and I respected them and you know one
hand washes the other and that's the way
it is how long we will uh patrol well
how old were you a patrolman or whatever
before you wanted to undercover hey the
truth I got out of college I went to a
university brassed Omaha oh sure don't
ask me why trouble there and I think it
was good that I got out there and you
know that a scholarship I was a little
old American out there and I was being
southeast district generally Golden
Gloves champion I've been did a lot of
[ __ ] I weighed me I my pet took me out
some crazy ventures but I wound up in
law enforcement I wouldn't wanted to be
phys ed teacher I wanted to work with
kids but you know had that fork in the
road and I took the one towards
criminology I graduated in that and
started my career there and and how long
he jumped into undercover right away was
it two years it would be when I started
in the prosecutor's office 1970 they
took me and not kind of try to like does
my we're invited to narcotics dialogue
not Irish
learning you know the ropes here and
then and then you know worked homicide
by six set all that stuff and after
about five years I really wanted to see
the difference
I wanted a big bigger venue and that's
why I wanted to build alcohol Tobacco
Firearms and from there the training
that I've learned and working with the
really the criminal enterprise
I believe listen I am my experience as
far as I'm concerned you know I did
would have to do I'm not saying I'm the
best in the world a lot of people make
mistakes out there what I was fortunate
enough to survive and many many
different undercover operations with
made guys you make them [ __ ] mistakes
in the streets you die you can make all
this mistakes you want at the academy
you get a second chance in the street
there's no second chance
what sort of specialty is there any sort
of special training that Undercovers get
or are they throwing you out like what
it like what do you do to prepare to be
a different person it's not that you're
let's back up a little bit a lot of
people think you know undercover you
look on the TV you know and you know
it's really cool you know I'm doing my
thing but the bottom line is they're you
know when you're in the Academy you
start learning the ropes a little bit
only what you're going to make your
bones is in the streets working with bad
guys okay you're not going to really
learn in the academy I was taking her to
a wing by a fella by the name Alex
Teatro okay he took me as a seasoned
agent he was my partner for many many
years and that his day was still very
close friends and
I also learned a tremendous amount when
I was occb from New York City came in
and they were looking for an Italian guy
that had some experience we would
infiltrate them up all five families all
five boroughs claim preparing one second
I just I'm sorry I just wanted to look I
just I just wanted I want to know like
do you start off with like smaller like
the model of all five families that's
that's a lot of experience yeah but you
start off slow my first the first I want
to bring up names but I went to Queens
I'm dealing with some heavy the first
time after we sat down with New York
City occb
and ATF who were in the office in
downtown Manhattan around five o'clock
and we talked to about a two-hours with
the source who was going on the witness
protection program
Casey hey listen this is my guy this is
the guy I want to work with meaning me
so what I did was we went out that night
and I met a made guy in Queens and he I
rented a sawed-off shotgun that that he
thought I was going to take off some
type of robbery at a place where we're
going to rob some Hummels and it just
snowball and terms and terminologies and
I was given information way back when
saying you know they don't say he's a
wise guy they said he's a good fella
that term was coined by my buddy who
went on a witness protection program and
what comes out several years later but
the movie Goodfellas and what you are
was a really good fella in order to use
the term wiseguy but it's a good fella
you know meaning hey he's one of us he's
part of the family so there's so much
involved with undercover where I get
talks regarding undercover operation
there's a lot of people that would like
to do it that aren't made for it and
there's a lot of things that I can do
that other agents and police all can be
very good at so you know my Mitchell
here the undercover operations in the
undercover work I grew up an Italian
neighborhood I was a kid I was driving
the load truck to make extra money
before with the high school I was 14
years old I'm over there delivering milk
before school and then I found a little
sign of money wrapped in paper and then
I came back to the truck and I said to
the judge what is this and he said hey
those dozen numbers I said would him in
numbers she should people pledge you
know a quarter for box straight you know
and collect the money didn't book me in
if they hit on a total mucho handle from
the Daily News then make a score this is
interested and I said yet so not only
was I making seven dollars a week
delivered no I was making an extra seven
dollars picking up the numbers so I was
making fourteen dollars a week I was
loading and I just started to learn the
information and some of the guys I grew
up with and certain neighborhood they're
a lot of guys went to jail you know for
robbery armed robberies and you know I
mean we knew one another and the bottom
line is they know what I did later on
and respected me and I respected them if
they need something they come and seen
it so I needed something I get the
information and one hand was here you
only learn that it really if you look
from the neighborhood and understand how
to obtains work you know when you go
when you sign a contract and
[ __ ] down to a piece of paper the
handshake the handshake that's it that's
all you need that's the bond that's the
bond is the handshake you boy back
you're [ __ ]
Dominick what really got me and Lee
going was well is in Boulder and when I
got out of prison
I worked at the car wash I was in the
halfway house and
and I was very intrigued with the
political system how I always was I mean
you know you even have an attorney
called Samuel DeLuca yes out of Jersey
after bad [ __ ] that was my mom's
and my stepdads attorney so Cubans
always played no hablo whenever you
arrest the cube and he don't know
nothing I don't I blow I do not blow so
they even play it to the attorney at
they don't hablo so I would have to go
to Jersey City and sit there with my mom
you know this is when she was big in the
numbers and remember in Jersey numbers
are a felony in New York thermos I mean
it what a [ __ ] scam you know so you
should be shot and hung if you do
numbers in New York boy you guys would
pay four dollars and takes all the
numbers you want in [ __ ] New York
City you get arrested in Jersey but I
was always very intrigued with it always
with the political system you know if I
wouldn't have gotten through a problem I
would have had I would have gone so I
was at the University of Colorado I'm
like you I was involved I was at your
[ __ ] nemesis growing up how [ __ ] up
is that I didn't want to tell you I was
so embarrassed so I wish we talked about
going to Boulder Degla what I was doing
undercover I flew to Denver I met a guy
over it with drop over the telephone I
flew there it was some type of bikers
okay and we started negotiating for
silences and I bought a couple of
silences while I was down in Pembroke
and then they delivered me 200 more
silence who's up at the Penn Station in
Newark and I and I got arrested they got
taken down you know there's so much
stuff working on Cherry Street with
that's the movie Frank Sinatra played
the detectives oh my god I was playing
I'm going to set I got tons of questions
for you yeah I mean I want to know what
there was an undercover cop what
happened was they would come into the
car wash and they would say Boulder
County Sheriff's Office so after a while
I figured out that these everybody all
the other mark cars came in but these
unmarked cars were like cutlasses and
these [ __ ] these these race cars and
I would and I started putting two and
two together these are undercover cops
so I became friends with one guy
and he didn't know my situation you know
even though I was on probation at the
house halfway house
we became tight I also became tight with
the DEA that's how I got out of my jam I
he said to have my attorney send them
emotion and then he would get me out of
the jam but this guy was telling me that
he wouldn't work cases in Boulder at
Denver that they would send him to Aspen
and Snowmass and the cops from Aspen
Snowmass would come to Boulder
why were you in your backyard you got
balls a [ __ ] steal no I don't know
about that but I tell you one thing I
learned a lot say this and you get a
feel of somebody you know okay we really
haven't met but we talked me we sort of
hit it off right here and you know you
get that Kimura tok your jersey
barometers you got you know you you
involved in some of the information that
I was involved with growing up as a kid
I mean we got that bond there man no
salmon you know the same people we know
so there's a lot involved here I mean
there's a lot of respect you know he's
big I mean when I was driving I had
Brandon Lincoln's I mean you know I'm in
the walk through law I mean I used to
quote basic all across the shock man I'd
be bouncing with that thing you know but
I did did so many different operations I
would get bearer bonds on consignment
five hundred dollar denominations on
confinement guys in the Bronx heavy
heavy made guys giving me Helen you know
I was dead there's a guy in Brooklyn
okay
it was called the Billa a GI he never
forgot it the village in Brooklyn and a
guy by the name of Mickey boy paradisio
ran it he saw me hijack roads and [ __ ]
untaxed cigarettes and I did and I want
a call about that and think Hilton bring
me one boy I release one I killed right
yeah he did I did someone by pavol yeah
he guys to make the to make a point he
was he was giving loaning money out as a
[ __ ] there's an eight
year old man the story that John eighty
year old man who was late on the payment
he went outside with the old man he
yelled to the neighborhood to look
nobody's looking and what happened he
took a settling torch and burned him
until he says tomorrow you come with the
rest of the money to make a payment
you never live with me he didn't care
because business is business that's the
way it is especially with these wise
guys you know they had to break bread
and stuff but don't give me that [ __ ]
[ __ ] power button go [ __ ] away you
know because some other mother will come
around and [ __ ] blow your brains out
so you got to know what the hell you're
doing
I take nothing for granted nobody for
granted when I'm in the street
I'm always business always you know I
don't want you to come on I don't need
this I don't need to go over here you
know help yourself with all these ladies
I don't need that [ __ ] you know so you
got to really know what the hell you're
doing otherwise you [ __ ] up now at
what point how many years were you an
undercover cop when you got the
assignment of your life wah wah wah
before this question I read the book and
they were saying that you did something
you busted want uh Sinatra's guys I know
that this protocol if you could tell us
the story it would make our dick hard if
you can't that's fine too you know I
still love you either way what I got
involved
I was working some of the families in
New York then what happened was I meet
this guy he's telling me a lot of guns
he's interested in selling guns but he
was a Jersey guy who was working on the
set as a makeup artist
he came yet yeah I need him we have some
coffee
under the Oh before they cook it down
and in New York and on the west side so
I mean I meet him and learn it he shows
me some guns on the set right on the set
where they doing the on Cherry Street
and crazy man I got I think that I may
still have blown up pictures of this
where was
on the set where he shall owe me guns in
all US and we must have saw me a total
of not only during operation maybe 50 60
guns and and the last time he brings it
with the bleeding bruises think he had a
young kid he brings on one of the one of
the buys and I climb the same through
the favorite son of a bringing boy yeah
like that and I'm only doing business
like if she's too young now you know
these guys won't like he is great you
know they don't think but big what we
had to do like both the guns and then
later on we took him down and then he
cooperated you know see a lot of times
when people go down I also get arrested
whether I use the name of Dominic Gucci
Dominic Michael Pullman mental or
whatever so you know that is what
happens to remove it so how do they do
the people who you're targeting not know
that you're an undercover until maybe
they see you in court on the stand like
if you get arrested so when I don't go
to put I don't go to court press is a de
my career I mean I testified I had to
testify okay what wouldn't happen later
on during these cases they got more
publicity they started a Current Affair
I mean with this particular case the
punch that was on everything from you
name it to Mary Hart
except what the program was with her
Mary Arden to handle you know I couldn't
I couldn't I anymore I mean this case it
happened to be one of my last cases and
the way one I'm gonna did a lot of
things but all right so we have to know
who you are you know I don't I don't
play somebody I am Who I am
look my name is Dominic powerful I use
the name Dominic Michael Corvin general
I met mister problems a no who
the union's growing up Tony Pro Tony Pro
that's right Tony Pro and I saw it and I
figured you know what I'm going to use
my name is Dominic Provenzano I got the
idea
my raps everything was Provenzano and my
car from that you know and I lived in a
high-rise and Fort Lee behind where uh
Palisades amusement park used to be you
know there's like 20,000 units all right
down decrease in all of them in those
buildings anyone remember what I had
yeah they worth checked me out what
happened is they had red flags on going
on the cover operation because New York
City took me in and took mug shots of me
you know for different crimes and stuff
and put me in the system so I had a
record and photographs and stuff like
that and but when things happen and when
they were west what they put out I mean
they just fled out so you know what to
trial yeah I went to trial on several
major cases but you know it didn't then
affect me I was fortunate okay so my
mother the last bus she took was 76 to
75
it was the numbers but it was numbers
with a little bit of conspiracy to drug
and what happened god what was a guy
from plov up guy from Paterson called
the bar number there was a bar a phone
number upstairs I was separate from the
bar they had the foam bar the number
tapped the guy from Paterson called the
street name was Paniagua bread and
butter bread and water because he was
like a Puerto Rican torture chamber
someone this [ __ ] guy so yeah after
the while they arrested my mother that
came to the house we knew the cops were
coming to the house so the house was
clean I got the call 15 minutes before
they showed up tell your mom to clean
the house and they just hung up the
phone and I told my mom and Spanish
clean the house I don't know what that
was and she did know there was not in
the house
anyway just a couple of whatever but
what we found out later on through San
DeLuca who was a [ __ ] Savage was even
as they were hiding the informants name
we found out the guys name
I mean we found out the [ __ ] guy's
name dollars so yeah my question is like
we found out from our attorney from De
Luca the Luke who spoke around give him
a week and it was funny how so me and
you I'm selling you two kilos and blow
you got arrested we both get handcuffed
together do it put us in the same jail
do I see you anymore or what happens to
be what happens is I give you the exact
Lisa never that went down I'm dealing
with a guy from jerking and this goes
down in Paramus New Jersey and the age
this guy walked with me silence which I
meet him i buy i buy three silences he
calls he says I do like them I should
really nice really quiet because how
many can you handle I say listen I said
you know maybe a couple more but that's
about it
he says can you handle another three a
flyby another three okay I let it go
he calls me almost every week
can you handle 50 can you handle 100 the
[ __ ] am I going to do with 100 I said I
can't handle or life God's honest truth
gets me and November December
she calls Jesus I want to know how many
you can handle I said you know what I'm
going to reach out I said how many can
you do rides on a judge he goes 3,000 I
said you can do 3,000 he says that's
right I said they're going to be nice 22
I stand a callable silence is very quiet
no manufacture serial number like you
sold me this is that's right I said okay
I said I can't promise you this but I
can't handle that I got to reach out to
someone if she's get back to me I make
some phone calls some shits going
through my head I should I
the perfect scam ila again a female
Asian Irish martial Irish Marge and I'm
going to flake Marge that's large the
troika lady I read you could go ahead
brother you got it I don't [ __ ] around
she plays the IRA I quote him back I
said listen I got a woman I said I'm
dealing with okay she'll take him
overseas but you work it with her I'll
be the introduction and stuff but you
know I said what do you want for that
for the three thousand she's a million
dollars cash I said oh I gotta talk to
her she was fine I get back to me let's
do the deal we do the deceit we do the
delivery Pearl Harbor day was December
7th I think in Paramus a design of a
buy-bust we got a planes up following
the truck you know the plane is the fox
and the rabbit is the truck the bad guy
we followed my sure enough he comes out
of the mountains up there and meets me
at the diner with the woman she's got in
that case a case he pulls up he comes
into the diner he says okay he says what
he got
as you look we talked to her she's
talked to me since I got the million
dollars I wanted I want Don to see the
silences gives me the keys I go to the
truck I open up it's like 60 boxes I
open boxes I think there was 20 or 50
silences in each box in some type of
oils no manufacturer or serial number
they were beautiful 3,000 of them I come
back out I close it I give the key back
him I said give him the money as they
give him the money she gets up and she
and over sudden all hell breaks loose
they arrested me and him they bring us
back the Paramus Police Department and
throws in the in the joint all of a
sudden were in a couple hours next to
each other
he's in a separate cell across from me
well that was get a knock
I hear porky his talk the [ __ ] going
on DEA comes in this guy named
Provenzano yeah we got a warrant for him
to distribute emajor kilos of cocaine
they take me they lock me up and take me
to the federal system and never to be
seen again he pled out you get my dress
yet no it's a beautiful thing that's
what I didn't know if you saw him again
because I know even in the cool Klinsky
case when he got arrested you really
wanted to be down there to put the cuffs
on and I understand after all the time
you could put in but they're like what
you know why go down there the thing
about this book that intrigued me the
most and I was telling me before you
called I know your time is short is your
[ __ ] in there with cool Klinsky
you're going down to the store in
Paterson you've got all these people in
your corner buddy is the weird thing
that I have one of your last meetings
they call you in you know per the book
and they they rip you a little bit and
they doubt you like these [ __ ] guys
that sit on a desk all [ __ ] day a
doubting you on with your job and they
go well maybe we'll bring somebody else
then Tom do you know how many times I
was in the 8th in the 90s I was around
drug dealers that would we would be
talking like Spanish kids it was nickel
and dime guys selling [ __ ] Abe walls
and quarter ounces and one day some
clown would just pop up with a friend
and go I want two pounds of blow and
they would come to me and go what do you
think and I go run like hell and change
a number so the guy you were selling it
to shows up one day with another white
dude and all of a sudden from buying
three-quarter grams and eight balls he
wants to buy a pound the blow and you're
looking to come to me are you [ __ ]
[ __ ]
you know they bloody not like I totally
from every hundred million pound or
every two hundred silence a deal there
is there's four of them that the feds
dropped the ball on because they
overthink the [ __ ] thing right when I
mean yep yeah
this kuklinski thing like you was this
started when I would let the
prosecutor's office and for several
years I'm in the streets in New York I
just finished up the a while ago you
know Lessing major plays and the five
families and everything so in 1980s I
get a call to come to the prosecutor's
office or those here on the state and
the prosecutor's office State Police and
we sit down and they give me a bunch of
information about this guy richard
kuklinski listen do harmonization and
they mentioned you know no disguise of
stone killer you know and that got a
family and but he uses poisons he says
but he's killing people we got
circumstantial evidence a lot of cracks
in it we need direct evidence from them
so we're asking me to meet a guy and
he's going to tell me how we murdered
five people you come to me and ask me
how I murdered people taken go [ __ ]
yourself exactly yes you understand not
let's just back up don't ask me why I
always had this [ __ ] knack for
whatever reason it is it is I can't
explain it I write up the report I sent
at the headquarters and they were kind
of concern because saying what the hell
is going on this is you know we're doing
with poison chance to get some you half
of dermis you know there's no antidotes
right away because she has the bike
because usually you want to do this I
said I want to do this I had to get a
declination from Washington and from the
US Attorney's Office in New Jersey and
anything that I do on this task force
will not go federal everything is going
to be turned over the state and they
want richard kuklinski for five murders
and they wanted me once i did meet him
to extract information how we murdered
certain individuals and what happened is
i started hanging out at the
or in Paterson New Jersey all these wise
guys Manuel hanging out there was
unbelievable just like Goodfellas man I
mean I thought they were for the movie
you know they could it be the movie
there it was unbelievable all these guys
would come in the cops would come by I
know on a Sunday I see them and they
just hijacked a whole load of tangental
umbrellas and it was throwing them into
the police cars and they would just take
it off there's a big line and a lot of
these guys would come into the store
looking you know for different avenues
and schemes from jewelry heist to
hijacking Lodz was amazing the network's
that they had and it took me over a year
I knew information would get out there
because what had happened is which
acoucookie was murdering certain people
that he had a little connection little
sell of mob guys in Jersey that he
wasn't happy with and he was killing
them and they weren't a part about it he
killed the guy by the name of Mister
Softee who was supplying him with his
sinusitis psi and I should say pure
cyanide and kuklinski murders this guy
now I'm hanging out at the store but
posted I don't 18 months approximately
and phone rings one day and it's died
picks it up which was sunny it's to you
the big guy wants to meet you and that's
what they refer to him as the big guy
and wants to meet you at the Dunkin
Donuts to talk some business and I we
were waiting for that because I was
doing a lot of legal business with these
guys and they were trusted Nick at the
store but nothing went down one day I'd
come into the store and I was on my way
in New York I pull in my link and I get
out went in that cash a case and
everyone well what was that assess for
people in the city and they were going
to come on come on what is it and this
was all prior plan I knew they would ask
what's in that attache case so I got a
pool
home Washington to go and we'll props
but they were certified props I walked
in and said come on let's take a look I
go in the back room I open up the
attache case and I got ten blocks of
plastic stolen explosives from the
military and I got ten high standard 22
caliber silences and they go on and we
can use the segregated medicines for
people in the city and they knew I had
all these connections and word was
getting out that I can get anything and
it got back to the big guy which is
known as kolinsky and when that phone
call came in I went to the Dunkin Donuts
and I meet him for the first time at
about 18 months and I had a lot of
information on him when he got out of
that Camaro this man he was like the
Jolly Green Giant he just grew and I
mean really about 64 to 70 big massive
guy with these orange tinge glasses and
he got out of that car as holy [ __ ] I
got out of my Lincoln I wrote a shaking
Chan and he had some mitts on him
believe me and he I thought he was
looking to take my soul out of my body
from those glasses when he was looking
at me and I'm saying to myself you know
kill a [ __ ] ain't getting my
soul that's for sure
and I could just feel him just looking
we go inside the Dunkin Donuts now this
is the glass on the food strike me dead
we sit down we have walking with talking
generalities and he goes can we get coke
I should I don't do coke he she knows
can you get coke and I said well I said
I think that'd be where you get a kilo
for I said about 32,000 which is where I
can get it for 28 I said we get better
off for your sauce and tensho he turns
to Maine now this is one of our first
conversation he goes but I don't know if
I can trust the guy so I look at him and
I said you a [ __ ] bunny and you must
have stared at me I'm telling you for
like seconds like I said he was trying
to burn my soul or take it out of me and
what I look and I'm run staring at him
you know you know tell somebody go [ __ ]
themselves but I've been around too long
I got the experience and I want to come
on I want it back off if you were to
back you off you want to eight you to
[ __ ] up alive and you know that well you
know they don't trust the guy I think
you a [ __ ] dummy yeah I don't deal
with anybody I don't trust and he asked
about five to ten seconds he goes you're
right so help me God when he said that I
said I got this [ __ ]
I felt that comfortable on our first
conversation then it came around you so
that you got connections that's yep it
doesn't say can you get cyanide because
can you get pure cyanide because you got
to know how to get the connections for
pure cyanide not go look at Audrey so to
get rat boys and we're going give me the
good quality and it smells like almonds
and you got to have a laugh person to
make this and he happened the killers
mr. Softee there and whose connection
for the pure cyanide and that started
the ball rolling when I kicked him
because I knew I needed issues I got
good care of some rat I said well I'll
tell you more hand washes the other you
got children say from them do they work
that I said I want some skill it was
still as you get nice and quiet you know
more a nice shake it I should that's
right I said nice and quiet I should be
better children say from me and he said
okay we walk out and shake and shake
hands and give me this telephone number
that I've had during the investigations
that they had that every player that he
gave wound up dead later on so I said
man this is working on Furcal
now this was a chance to meet so he
leads I ride around I go to a pay
telephone I drop to dine my cool I said
listen I just met
Kuklinski it seems like about 11:30 now
12 o'clock when I tell you all hell
broke loose all hell broke loose
at 3 o'clock they said there's a big
meeting you know what was suits you're
going to be there what I'm telling you
is unbelievable
every from the Attorney General new
neighbor was Beth and this is going to
be one of our first meetings and when I
went back was sitting there where
everybody's just coming in and I haven't
met this guy he was a major and I'm not
going to get in with the palm the wood
and say grandma she's come over here I
want to talk to you brings me in the
room now a lot of different heads of
agencies you coming in now and Deputy
Attorney General Carol who I work with
prior I did a lot of undercover
operations to them with the attorney
general's office and the Essex County
prosecutors will say they knew me so
quiet to that I walked in with this
superior those smelted system variances
this is what you're going to do you're
bowing out of this investigation you're
going to introduce um one of my guys and
see what he says do you hear what I'm
saying now they're very you know what's
the word I'm looking for you do very
white regiment read every read and write
very Rick let's say I surrender finally
vanishes
you're bowing out and you introduce some
c'mon oh my god shows it don't work like
that
we don't work 18 months you need a guy
finally you got a reputation and all of
a sudden they introduce about new
ballast it don't work he says you're
going to do that and I should go [ __ ]
yourself
and I got up and I walk out he's letters
of beep work out and get the deputy
attorney general Bobby Kevin knows that
what's going on and I told him because
what he goes we'll keep a clear head
here so if somebody goes around and they
all sort of cable
they sell right Donna tell us what
happened told them I you know I met
Cooper
Amy's number told me the pure cyanide I
said I couldn't believe that time first
time we met so he says we should take
and it wasn't take the first time so I
said listen while we're talking my pager
goes off it's for Penske so they ask
what's that and I should discover she's
so this major goes get a tape we're
going to record snow in our table we're
not taking I'm not table that is a big
arguments going on
if anybody's [ __ ] outside you're
going to be responsible I should [ __ ]
you I put five people together be your
wing I said so don't give me this [ __ ]
I said everybody this guy works for when
he says jump you jump I'm talking about
crispy and he'll tell you where to come
down I said ain't happen with me I said
he's got something that I had that he
needs and he's got to show good faith to
me and it was a lot of [ __ ] going on a
lot of a lot of diss questions and they
fight finally the AG's office the
Attorney General that was going to
prosecute him with the four the five
maurices we're already done and you can
heard a pin drop in the pages of any
[ __ ] body else dies you're
responsible you know we're going back
for the scope [ __ ] himself you know I
don't work for them I work for the
government you know and so they con very
clean that and they formulated this task
force when they wanted me now to stop
meeting with closely and gather
information how we murdered people and
which he you know this spiral was a mass
murderer I mean this guy loved the kill
I mean he loved it even the way he
talked he he would carve a niche for
himself you know he this is me you know
he's a cold-blooded son of a [ __ ] I can
feel it he just loved what we just when
he talked about learn if you can see in
his eyes it was like him staring and
getting a hind was unbelievable and then
he's telling me how he's going to people
there was a lot of information that I
gathered you know one he said you know I
made the cops look like [ __ ] I
should go cannot be what it is I got a
guy in a prison for two years so what he
had a guy in for two years
he should and I put in I put them in
baggies and I buried them in the freezer
and after two years I dumped them and I
think it was out West Milford area New
Jersey and so jog or something found the
body called the group and the individual
mask' his name was Lewis mask' that was
murdered and kept in a freezer did not
be composed he had the same clothes he
had on that he disappeared two years ago
information did not people vote so when
they took him back to be the autopsy
this is like in August and September and
as they started doing a found these ice
crystals like in the body you know and
said something wrong there something's
definitely wrong
get further information they found out
that this guy was Lois mad day we met 15
years ago that disappeared now kakuka
show me how we murdered them and how we
kept them in a freezer now you may try
to make the cops look like asses with
this with the smoke there's fire issues
but they can never find the fire because
features I'm too good at what I do is
let me tell you something just so you
know he says I should do a commercial so
what do you mean a commercial which is
his flimsy illnesses I buried the guy in
plastic garbage bags you know what kind
of used I is glad he said now people
should go out and buy glad he could they
last a long time I mean any would smile
you know I'm saying I'm saying to myself
holy [ __ ] this this is the devil this is
definitely the devil you know I'm
getting all this information from this
bad and he feel uncomfortable telling me
how he's running
you know how he murdered the people with
them with you yeah cyanide how we put it
on their hand burgers and you know and
amazing just amazing you know I buy the
silences from them he showed the faith
he feel uncomfortable and I don't know
if you remember this but during that
time going on doing this undercover
operation there was cyanide scare with
Pinal you remember right yeah yeah I
think it says Lipton but I thought in 82
somebody did something with pollen all
right so what I happened he said to him
is this is ironic and this is true there
were a cyanide scared they were finding
cyanide somebody was injecting into the
tunnel of capsules they were breaking
the seal and doing that so I felt oh
maybe I don't be careful when I do
things it's like said you know I said I
had this I had the cyanide for you I
said but I'm not keeping up with he
they're going to think that I'm the one
have been doing the capsules in Jersey
and he bought it boarded home taking his
time the back walk a little bit to
gather more information but this guy was
a cold calculating son of a [ __ ] of
murder the only thing is you don't [ __ ]
with his family he had a family you love
but you know one good deed doesn't
deserve another with this guy and I knew
down the road that I was dealing with an
animal and you know you got to keep your
sense who the [ __ ] you on and we used to
hang around with a guy by the name of
Roy the mail in the gem-knight lounge in
Brooklyn New York and that's when he
could chop up the bottoms and Roy DeMeo
was a made guy in New York and I believe
Jerry Capricia wrote about him in his
book and murder machine or something
like that and the mail was going to be
arrested
alone for committing 64 homicides by
himself
I mean they had some group gathering yet
it was unbelievable malignant in ski
really killed the male is here I thought
it was uh I don't I don't want so I
don't find that I think it was the
Calculon from the Gambino's that shot
him
yeah today's very comical they know who
murdered the DeMaio and it was not cool
it was not GU Klinsky because and they
had I would like a chance Allah was on
the compet yeah from the time ya got you
met him
to the time he got arrested how long was
that process as crazy as it sounds I met
in September so September October
November December how much I got all the
information that I needed on tape from
the murders and form circumstantial
evidence that they had I filled the
cracks with documented direct evidence
from his mouth probably murdered these
individuals now you mentioned how he had
been killing a lot of people who you
work with in and I heard something that
you said you had a gun in a special
pocket on you at all times
what yeah what was that yes I think that
was the line was how are you reading
I had a 380 caliber pistol in my left
pocket on right-handed but I kept I
focal my right hand you know our times
but I had the gun pointed at him and
during this investigation I said he was
known as putting cyanide in the spring
and spraying it into people and he on
cake there's several conversation within
trying it out in New York where he give
them a boost he called it then watch the
guy who looks like he died of a heart
attack walking in the street he told me
a couple times he went and that he
wanted dinner with somebody put a boost
in the pump as the bad one for the bat
and come back mixing the cyanide in it
and all of a sudden the bag drops gonna
cool everybody screams go to that
o'clock died of a heart attack he gets
up visually and walks away
yeah
this is generator I mean cause I Coulomb
started this investigation and started
this conversation between of course K
and mu is actually which not the retin
this is a traditional bottom surface
tension when we had many taped
conversations that could ever understand
you I said I kill people with guns
if you mission my friend you can do it
that way but my way is nice and clean
nobody looks like we should be given a
boost
now when renting patience feels very low
because it makes you look like you want
about an artifact because or if your
client wants a statement made I can make
a message I can cut it come out stick it
up his ass to the canary in the guides
mouthing there's a lot of ways to
business but I like my nation claim you
should there's no mess because a couple
of times I got the body he should live a
more to set inside he would change sort
of cut the tendon so I can get him in
the bow of the temple and that's the way
he was I mean he he'll was unbelievable
he was she was you know school hard hard
knocks had a rough time growing up but
we all did
you know I mean that's the way it was
back home in Jersey you know especially
in certain areas you lived it you know
you know look I mean it has been so many
things written about him and everything
I mean the one of the things we
mentioned that he mentioned we had to do
a contract it he went to see somebody I
think it was in the movie that works
sure out where he goes to the player who
makes them and the guy goes which in
which you please preach don't murder the
god plea because I play a while because
the six o'clock he said 6:30 Jesus
Christ comes down you're freemen 6:31
banging Beck Commission slicing them
they're new
he said no beginning is real lucky that
our past didn't cross because all these
places I used to go to Liberty Hotel
York Hotel 78 the Newkirk my friends and
Rago god bless his soul lived i walked
past that [ __ ] garage 20,000 times
you know the default diner on route 3
are you [ __ ] crazy by the Clifton
then when the Clifton the driving was
out there and we were kids then yes that
diner on Bergen Boulevard the Sky View
Hotel I stayed and lives down the block
one of my all-time favorite restaurant
when you had the Department of Fort Lee
called pica we seem oh you know you know
the first thing I think was the off
motel that's where he had been I chop
down yet cyanide on the hamburger and
then watch the victim died in the bed
and then he strangles him with the cord
after their lesson because he said to me
I had the [ __ ] guys and I told the
players weren't more obsessed when the
hamburgers come in don't eat the ones
with the pickles don't eat the ones with
the pickles so he gives the ones with
the pickles to one of the people he
kills in New York motel with cyanide he
goes the guy had a constitution from
[ __ ] mode quote from him he goes done
which is on sickening hitting the whole
Hamburg of watching or watching he says
finally the [ __ ] guy died heroes
always he animals ate the whole damn
burger you know and pie and then into
the circumstantial evidence and getting
the direct at the chocolaty
was unbelievable how we type every
single morning and every night when I
used to meet will cook good food I was
like what the tape can Paul Smith one of
the investigators and then I need them
later on at the grant we had running
walk of black
Scotch with the couscous picture on it
and I during this whole investigation we
must I went through 20 bottles you know
born over you know information that we
needed this I needed that I needed this
for this
in case dr. Lila Culver I got no [ __ ]
room upstairs man I need a break here
you know I mean it was was constantly
ongoing and I didn't really live far
from him you know when I was doing this
investigation
I've lived in one town which was really
about maybe 10 miles from where he was
and do mark New Jersey our past and of
course any any place any time at that
[ __ ] at that supermarket in Cresskill
you could have been anywhere one last
question for you brother
it says in the book so I gotta ask you
because we've had a we had salut box on
the show you know who salut boxes he oh
he's a lot he's the first guy to roll on
John Gotti
so the heroin small-timer he lives right
around the corner from my office witness
relocation plan had two sons played
profession that's why he said he got
into a witness relocation plan because
of his boys and the playing pro football
ah but I mean you're in the book here it
says that you also had busted Vinny Gani
that's true kromagg met Vinny Gotti on
Bath Avenue with matter of fact in
Brooklyn I think we're right now that
film John Gotti with the another Jersey
Galya was playing him Travolta John
Travolta are they really filming on it
are they really feel like I met I met
the younger goddess at the bedrock bar
on Bath Avenue in Brooklyn New York and
I flipped in the next amount of dollars
and he came back later on where you
stationed them
I think she she was delightful is
showing me that word had one on hand to
n101 and Batman no or whistle where
these guys would hijack roads and stuff
and swagging or like they take care of
the neighborhood first which is not take
care of the neighborhood whatever it is
clothes and food this way where the cops
come nobody know I know we know nothing
we know nothing
you know this
motion involved bad Magaluf chrissake
Sammy the Bulls on a bud
well how many was I look at one of the
players I was dealing with a Bronx and
this was a made guy which nobody fronted
money I twenty ten thousand dollars I
many mapping J at Kennedy Airport I
flunk it in ten thousand dollars I'm
waiting at the airport Motel debt at JFK
he comes back within two hours he called
me every 15 minutes what I was hooked up
with a made guy in Manhattan he delivers
me three more packets of heroin he
hunted in ten when he came back with
together to I gave him an additional
$20,000 we made $30,000 that night my
name was gold and no arrests ever with
allocating silences on in Riverside and
Riverside at the diner from this Greek
diner
Joey sick he being the bleeding murdered
peanuts and nothing Yonkers I can't
forget a name right now nice to meet him
he needs to go by the name of Joey sick
a big guys look so many plays involved
with all this it was wild you know you
may wanna make a parody show before let
me tell you who that is I just remember
who that was there was a war between the
Lucchese and John Gotti what was the guy
that took over after the guy went to
jail him and Vince amou so Vic Vic Amuso
and the other [ __ ] guy
well that Mickey paradisio had a problem
with him and sent two guys to shoot that
guy at a Chinese restaurant do you
remember that story he went into the
restaurant and that's what saved his
life and when he came out he went yeah
he went to Guardians that I want Mickey
they
give him Mickey because he was a
big-time heroin dealer she was big-time
Mickey yeah yeah that's what it was so
now like Judah a wandering eye I would
get a call from occb
Tom you gotta meet me at the Meadowlands
actually come on I'm just got home no
you gotta meet me there I want you to
meet Harry to pick [ __ ] that's all
right I go meet them at a pre-designated
area and meet Harry to pick Carrie comes
in we're at the Meadowlands at the
Meadowlands Racetrack carry contain this
is Sonny from New York a eyes above a
bum start walking he knew I was hooked
up I read a pic went around to the mob
you know it was a op not safecracker and
would open up any safe and we would get
10% of the booty in sight that no other
person can open up and say she cry all
over the country and I needed to know
what's in the suitcase that he was
involved with when she told me did in
Queens and he gets 10% of the money I
mean he says unbelievable unbelievable
they had a network that was phenomenal
phenomenal Dominic's who I know was
nothing all over the place nothing
really quite a logical yeah but but it
is what it is right now you know it's
funny like you said in the beginning
it's really weird that I passed didn't
meet because when I was 14 that was
wrong with to that metal hands at
Pegasus and my friend's father oh yeah
and my friend's father why my buddy was
the head chef at the [ __ ] that Pegasus
Benny Lynch so I would go and I would
walk in there you'd have a jacket and
then walk in there like Johnny Bananas
when I was 15 the summer before my
mother died Jimmy my friend Jimmy knew a
lot of guys down there so he would go
I'm going to bring it down there at
night so when somebody wins a trifecta
you cash it for them and they give you a
little taste so I would go down to all
social security card and I clean up like
I get like 10% during next to 20 you
know I go home with 300 is a [ __ ]
freshman in high school
that's a squat even that's the only I
made like $82,000 at the track that year
I mean I didn't really want any money
Dominic I love you brother I even the
dine alone is I told they would go play
this bubble game all the time over from
the jersey would go into a Serie Queens
and they claimed a book upstairs to a
private game dad bounces that made NFL
players look like midgets unbelievable
but tons of money turns in books
anything you want and everything they
report to one Godfather discrete guy and
he will use the name as petrol up there
and he wanted me to blow up the
Claremont diner on move three years ago
I what happened was take this pipe on
that gives ago my god the Claremont
diner
listen I know you got to go to gentlemen
I really it's been an education this
week and only ill education I got to
meet a really great guy you're a special
[ __ ] guide Dominic God I wish we had
more time to really go quite a logical
oh no no I'll call you I'll call you
next month again we'll do this these
guys are gonna love this I mean you're a
great guy and God bless that nothing
ever bad happened to you man they don't
make sighs just like Jamie and your
family and everything else
be safe and I really enjoyed this and
I'm gonna give you a call tomorrow find
out exactly what's what would you have
any questions for my uncle Dominic just
really quick something that we've heard
about on the show and I just want to
know if you've heard about it have you
ever heard of the Meadowlands in little
that Chelsea that wasn't that small
little place that was a small little
Barney loved Bergen where women would
stick bottles in their [ __ ] and [ __ ]
from 79 to like 81 it was owned by North
Bergen police Norfolk cops had that's
what a long [ __ ] time ago Madonna
yeah long time well you know with your
goobers cappuccino and
gloppy that's funny and the other guy
making small world I love you I love my
brother and I will call you this week
and I thank you for your time I know
it's valuable and I have a fan
but uh I will be in touch with you a lot
Dominic thank you very much for taking
the time when I god bless you
thanks a lot not a lot be speaking I
really appreciate it I really enjoyed
this lovely big thank you bye-bye would
you think of Emily it's uh it says it it
sounds he's so calm about it he's
talking about it like when he was when
you guys are talking about Colorado
anything I flew the Colorado ones and I
saw these things he's talking about like
it's a vacation like like how we talking
like oh I got this to eat in Colorado
once he like I went to Colorado and all
these sandwiches you know it's uh I've
always been very interested with
undercover work how I didn't end up
doing it guys is beyond me I didn't
become a kite even know about this
undercover work so it was too [ __ ]
late I had felonies you know but it's
always intrigued me this conversation is
good for me because it closed it the
questions I had about the Iceman and
just meeting this guy just talking to
him on the phone about what was what
really went down you know I bought the
other book first the one by Carlos
something Carlo the Iceman and like I
said it was a lot of I felt it was a lot
of rhetoric and a lot of nostalgic guy
trying to build himself up the one they
based a movie off the Iceman this book
by Anthony Bruno this was the one that
really brought a lot of things to life
I'm happy I picked up like I said guys
you're not only dick if you don't read a
book a week or book every two weeks I
know people busy man and some people
want to go back to school but they don't
have time to what's the better thing to
do than read and I don't cost you know
you go to the [ __ ] library you check
out a [ __ ] book and you read and you
bring it back man a lot of people
suffering just at home wasting that time
I'd rather if you're watching six hours
you're watching six hours of TV a day
you and you're on the [ __ ] computer
three hours a day that you can't win
about an hour of any [ __ ] book that
interests you just to get your mind off
at least you can have a conversation
with somebody and
about about something moral you can't
have a conversation with TV or social
media just yeah and that's something
that I haven't done since high school
probably ya know we all forget that
greening is [ __ ] fundamental when I'm
having a hard time writing I go to
reading I start reading my [ __ ] ass
well you know this week I gave book that
I gave Lee that book the art of war
which a lot of you have sent me pictures
on Twitter and whatnot you know the main
thing about that book is the word
resistance the word resistance is a
[ __ ] that I have it this morning
I haven't every day for something
different every day you talk yourself
out of doing something different if you
read the book The Art of War
here's your homework assignment world
war two weeks the art of war whatever
the [ __ ] the world are if this is the
[ __ ] this is your homework assignment
your homework assignment is basically to
catch yourself every time your
resistance comes up catch yourself see
how many times the [ __ ] de resistance
shows his ugly face to you you know all
I want to go work out I'm gonna take a
run and something something else happens
you don't want to do it and there's
always you know I have friends that Lee
and I were talking about a certain
friend of mine that we'd love to Det he
does this type of work but he puts that
up first to take away from what's really
going on like wait a second I didn't
work on this today because I did this
that's another form of [ __ ]
resistance it's the same [ __ ] thing
and it's it's hard because those are the
frustrating part for me in the book is
he made it he makes it seem like it's up
daily like a daily battle you everybody
has it I'm a daily [ __ ] basis you
know everybody [ __ ] hands on a daily
basis so just to touch on that the art
of war the war about whatever the [ __ ]
it is the most important thing is that
it's you find yourself getting the
resistance he's a right hi you look
overcoming or just work against it
that's what I usually do now you know
you give yourself a goal I'm going to go
to the gym three times a week every day
I'm gonna go to the gym this week at 12
from 4:00 to 5:00 I'm gonna write
[ __ ] poetry get them time I don't
give a [ __ ] what gets in your way
nothing could get in your way of that
you know if you come to
in the wall I did kettlebells and said
that that that that that don't mean
nothing you supposed to [ __ ] right
that's what was supposed to be done
nothing else I don't give a [ __ ] and
that's what I had to realize over the
years that's what I had to realize over
the years I thought the date time was to
go talk and play with your [ __ ] goofy
friends who got nothing going on no the
date time is to write and to send emails
and to [ __ ] you know get your day
together like every day you have to have
a different mission and this is what
this book teaches you I don't want to
frown on that book we'll get back to but
the homework assignment for the war of
art of the author war whatever the [ __ ]
it is is that you catch yourself you
resistance and acknowledge it that's it
now back to this [ __ ] book over here
and it was just what really intrigued me
about this book was what he said guys
from 1979 to 1985 I raise [ __ ] hell I
couldn't a lot of bad things going to
come to me I'm not going to City and
tell you all I could have got killed
they no no no no no no no no but read
these [ __ ] places where I verified
with you guys I'll have all these places
I was doing something except for the
place in Patterson that he talks about
in the book the shack where people go
this is a story about him going in there
Dominic and some that pulls in besides I
got a half a million in fives get
counterfeit giving to me for 20 cents on
the dollar
he's like one thing I do fight on [ __ ]
of those you know that's a complete
different world that people don't know
and I love when people try to go into
that world on when you watch TV and you
see a person between 20 and 29 get
arrested for something really crazy it
was that he got himself into a world
that he didn't know existed
he watched something on TV and that's
the difference a lot of people have
never realized that in life and that's
why I tell people you make any of those
type of moves that you only get a kilo a
blow or and I don't so blow the sell it
and make money think about what you're
doing and think about the people you'll
be dealing with you know Lee and I've
been talking a lot the last couple weeks
how the people we deal with our lives
and the daily basis here
I'm a comedian I'm very proud to be a
comic man there's a lot of comics I like
there's a lot of comments that dislike
just like you guys as co-workers you
like and this co-workers I dislike one
of the main things I hate about comics
are that they will take the most from
you for the least of money they will
take more [ __ ] from you and try to get
away with paying you the cheapest that
I've ever seen before and what they do
is comedians is they don't take care of
the areas that they have to take care of
like they'll spend money a lot of money
I don't want a web page but they won't
spend money on the guy that treats him
from like they got to drive them down
and try to be cute like drive me down
and I will have to save on a plane but
I'll give you a hundred for gas take
care I could give him the extra [ __ ]
hundred giving me extra [ __ ] hundred
take care of people if you notice Lee
doesn't do any podcast and then the
other [ __ ] comedians because he heard
he learns the hard way except to speak
Simone he learned the hard way that with
comedians they want to give you 10 bucks
or they're always late or there's always
a [ __ ] problem or there's always you
know and Lee paid me a great comment
last week he'll you know what it's crazy
you're my best client aside from the
drugs and the stories in the prisons and
all the craziness and the stealing I
gotta hand it to you you come through
like a [ __ ] ace it it's almost it's
funny but in my head if I had if you had
told me this when I first started that
it's not even close guys like it really
just isn't even and I'm not saying that
it's always like a breeze like it's
always like sunshine and happy flowers
like there's we work hard and sometimes
it's hard but it's not even like oh
there's a close second to like just just
like being on time like just quickly
about the war of art he said like you do
all this stuff you do what you're
supposed to do for your job you like you
most of the time you go to work on time
you do all that and then you're hurting
yourself personally and you all these
people that have dealt with are all
self-employed essentially and you
shouldn't you shouldn't be my worst
client like you in theory late yes never
showing up another paying on time
a check bounced always a story tired met
no no I have treated this like a [ __ ]
soldier and because I wanted to give you
the respect that you deserve which a lot
of people never think about other
people's feelings and what they go
through some people live their life
never considering anything else I love
when people call me and say hey you know
flying to New York I had a situation
this week where a family friend friend
the sisters sick so I called my friend
like I'll go see your sister and stuff
so I'll reach out to the whole family I
reach out to his brother
we haven't spoke in a while I apologize
I tell them what's going on with my life
you know the most like hit me back I
said listen when I go home next time
let's uh it's break bread man let's eat
something and let's catch up on let's
get this animosity beside us I'm getting
too old you're getting too old this
problems assist it has existed between
us this little riff I mean we've been
friends but we've had a riff since 1981
that's 26 years we want some being the
closest people in the world to people
who wave at each other and say hello and
if you don't think it bothers me after
all he did for me you're out of your
[ __ ] mind so I hit him up we talk we
go back and forth on Facebook he says
yeah I'm gonna meet with you guess what
this [ __ ] said to me so let's do
this let's forget to dinner why don't
you just fly out August 11th and do my
function for me and the mayor is gonna
be there and all these people gonna be
there on my egg how did it go for me
going back there to the Borgata July
29th and meet you for lunch then flying
back there to do your [ __ ] event at a
at a kind of thing like what justifies
you ask me that and weird how it goes
from friendship it's at all yeah like
what Justin do you even have a clue what
goes on in my life you don't have a
daughter you don't have
do you know I do a podcast twice a week
you know I'm trying to [ __ ] lose
weight so I try to focus on my work out
my breathing my eating to some again I'm
trying to write a book you also know I'm
trying to write material for stand up on
my stand up is [ __ ] hurting so what
you want me to do is get on a thirteen
[ __ ] hour flight six each way plus the
hour plus the hour to drive past the
[ __ ] ubers to come to your event I
wish I could just do that all the time I
wish I had a helicopter which I could
just people don't give a [ __ ] and if you
think the people in the Midwest don't
give a [ __ ] like they're a little rude
not even compared to what we deal with
out here Charlie had a podcast for a
year the guy was late every week every
week there was always a story there was
always for people with him at the dinner
one they miss the hall it'd take
weddings I got right to this wedding in
two weeks this is between your guy guys
I really want to go when I talk to her
you got to hear her on the phone she has
not considered me by no means or what's
included in my world or what's going on
and I understand it's your big day but
you never asked me about my day and what
I'm doing on that day that's why when I
got married I got married on the
Wednesday before Thanksgiving because I
wanted people to be in town I didn't
want to take away from nobody my wedding
was from three to seven dog I got
married at one the party started at 3:00
and everybody went home at 7:00 I didn't
make it to go to understand me there's
people that I'm having this event in
Montecito you would walk that's a two
hour drive so you're asking me for four
and I have a child you know and that's
what I don't I'm not even playing that
normal over people like I'm not even
playing that game them over people like
that that's not gonna exist
I don't you know I'm going to USC fight
with Jones a buffalo guess what I'm not
saying for that [ __ ] fight don't do a
[ __ ] Jesus fighting I'm not picking
up an envelope stop coming over my
family so we perform at levity live more
[ __ ] weeks from six hours away both
[ __ ] weekends you think I'm gonna sit
there and extra [ __ ] day to watch a
fight you crazy best place I'd watch the
fight is in myself in living room with
my feet up picking my [ __ ] nose you
know that's the best way
you know that's the best time I have is
watching that type of [ __ ] at my house I
don't want to go there I'm 54 years old
and you're not fighting your nature
being stuck in for what what's the
purpose I got on a plane to pick up an
envelope and bring it the [ __ ] back to
my family I don't have time to get on a
plane to go to a wedding or if the
wedding is there when I'm going back to
do the comedy sure I'll stop by in the
afternoon say hello and drop off a
[ __ ] well I'm broke I'm not an animal
by note by no means but you know but you
they also still have to uh understand
what the [ __ ] I'm doing
absolutely let me do some shoutouts real
quick Philadelphia croc Collins Chris
Hines who else is on here laughable
current Michael John Doherty beware
podcast Tyler true Burke Dom T and Derek
sparks I love you [ __ ] don't
forget I'll be at levity live West Nyack
Thursday Friday and Saturday this
weekend and then 420 levee live Oxnard
right here in California bro blowing
this place down all right so that's that
that was very interesting his call
because I had never really we never had
an undercover cop on here before and
we've never really had anybody of that
act I think we had a cop on town when I
did Beauty and the Beast why absolutely
we never had a copier before and I
wanted to really go into this you know
he was talking about mr. Softee like I
said Lee when we did the documentary and
we went on Charles Court I showed you
exactly in conjunction how far I was
from my house to mr. [ __ ] softies
house you know this guy mr. swap he
talks of buy him the book is really
interesting because he had two boys and
a great wife a beautiful [ __ ] wife
and we all played together and the boys
with great boys I know one of them
passed away he died in the car accident
God rest his soul but the younger one
that's still alive I think changed his
name and he contacted me about five or
six months ago
on Facebook and you know my normal
horror adage would been to I mean I
haven't told him since he was a child
I'm not gonna live nobody inside I keep
in contact with him but my natural [ __ ]
attitude was to contact it on Facebook
and have him call the podcast to talk
about his [ __ ] father who was an
animal they couldn't wait I didn't have
the heart in me you know if he listened
to the podcast and he would like to call
him now and tell his thoughts on his
father amen
I give him all the power in the world
I'm not mad at him it's just something
that happened but here's the crazy thing
I officially left Jersey at 85 and maybe
Ford you know what pronged egg did baby
to do you know he did he put a bomb in
front of his [ __ ] house to kill his
wife for his kid I hear you said like
way on the street now on the balcony on
the porch [ __ ] like this is this is this
[ __ ] guy lived around the block from
my house do you know I was all like
another people think you're lying but
like you've indicated having Dominic on
the phone he'd like just that he's like
yeah I mean he knew your lawyer how
crazy is that
listen bro I don't really give a [ __ ]
what these people believe what they
don't believe because at times I'm doing
something I get little messages like you
know this is this if you don't believe
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about after
all these [ __ ] years then go watch
[ __ ] Star Trek or you go watching our
agents to the windshield whatever the
[ __ ] that show is or you know these are
the same people that watch that
shouldn't believe that you know I listen
I've been doing this I'm 54 [ __ ]
years old vote and I'm posh I'm really
80 and cat years diems I and I've been
very [ __ ] fortunate to live a bad
life and I've been very fortunate to
have a good life
jeez I'm sorry I mean it's very hard to
describe what that means you know from
zero to 15 I had a very good life I had
a couple notches in there with my family
I wished I had more from my family or
more but
that's the way life turns out I had a
beautiful relationship with my mother
and God took her away her taking her
away made me a better [ __ ] man from
16 to listen you know 40 was it
basically a failure just holding on and
the only thing that kept me alive was
his [ __ ] stand-up and in all that
time I got a story for each of those
[ __ ] days and I wearing from either
being a piece of [ __ ] or being a good
person you know 10 years ago I decided
to stop doing cocaine which was really
holding me down you know I got 37 years
of stories of cocaine I got 17 years of
stories but I probably forgot that when
I go home people remind me of little
things I always [ __ ] I kind of forgot
about all this I have never told anybody
I'm a bad person
I've told people I've made mistakes and
I was putting different positions by my
own hand no it wasn't really fault it
you know no no no I have a great life
man I've learned a lot of things and
number two I've met a lot of great
people and I've said that yeah the
sadness in my life d-damn is that God
took my life you have a little my mom's
life and my dad's of the young age and
you have a little anger to God I don't
have that anger no more because it made
me a part of who the [ __ ] I am today and
one of the things that comes it is the
stories why do you think I yell at you
every [ __ ] day to get out of the
house I want everybody to live a full
[ __ ] life and if you know what if
that means experimenting with an ice
cube Li and putting a little hats on
there you alive absolutely and anything
happened to you your kidneys damaged did
you jump out a window could you have a
bad trip I'm teeth all I'm trying to do
is help you reach out a little bit I
never wanted to lead to be a criminal or
still coke or or gambled or
and I don't want that to any of my
[ __ ] friends I know what your actual
life I went through I didn't more I'm
here for you
I'm here so you can [ __ ] and learn but
if you learn anything they may learn two
things set tell the [ __ ] truth and
live your life and go balls for the
[ __ ] wall
who gives a [ __ ] at the end of the day
it's like when you go bowling I always
think I'm a bowling ball for me to do
the best [ __ ] thing to get a strike
what happens there's pins laying
everywhere it's like I dropped a grenade
that's people's feelings that's people's
emotions that's people who didn't
believe in me and on the other side
those the same people who did believe in
me you know for you to do what you want
to do in life you know you're gonna make
somebody unhappy somebody's gonna be
unhappy you gonna call home tomorrow and
go mama become a cop and she's gonna go
no you're not but your dad's when you'll
say godly you always make no matter what
decision you make somebody's gonna be
[ __ ] unhappy with some my wife's gonna
put up a hand like Joey's only four five
day but for you to accomplish what you
need to in your life as a human being
you have to live this [ __ ] life and
that's it it's how hard I guess I
struggle daily was not caring about what
people think and that's that's a huge
thing oh [ __ ] look what you did like I
never want to make anybody unhappy i I
really don't but and that's where like
with other podcast whatever whatever
work you're in we have you call me
tomorrow right and say to me Joey I
can't do the podcast because me and Paul
going along beating done I don't need
that in my life
right yeah but if you call Mingo can we
put the podcast on Thursday night
because I really wanna go this poker
tournament it means the world to me
you know what Lee I'm gonna be mad at
you fade minutes and then I'm gonna go
this is what this kid wants to do and
then it's all gonna be forgotten it's
all gonna be forgotten whether you want
to lose you took the experience I think
right now and on a society people aren't
taking the funk like I said you know I
found the pill in my pocket that's all
the joke and I took it there was one of
Larry's
yom-yom pills people wouldn't do you
know and I'm not saying - I'm not saying
to do drugs would be a fee for that no
no no no no no I'm talking to find that
what you really want this [ __ ] life
you gotta get up off the couch and get
out of goddamn house you know for the
last couple of months we've been
scratching the surface you and I talking
about podcasting and podcasting and
podcasting and one day you came to me
you know what man I want to be a
professional gambler but I get married I
say we but no you're gonna be a thousand
things before you're 30 years only I'm
sorry to tell you for you to really
really have a great life man you gotta
have variety you might kiss 20 [ __ ]
women and one's gonna steal your car
one's going to give you ridi but
eventually you're gonna meet that one
that really rocks you or you just might
meet that one there's people that have
20 jobs before they find a job they want
that's what happened to me
you think that I had it easy people yeah
they somebody wrote on Twitter I wish I
had your life because I wonder I know
you did you don't create on your own you
know on my [ __ ] life I don't want my
[ __ ] life at times I think about
sleep on those buses and and robbing
people's houses in court rolling through
a window you think I don't think of
these things at night or every three
days the things I've done and I think of
the good things I did like I said the
other day
I'm not [ __ ] funny you think I'm
funny you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] your
[ __ ] ass I'm after loaded into the
podcast yeah the [ __ ] the only thing
that you could get out of me is the
talent it took to get here the talent it
took to go to bed crying every night and
say this is what I want to do the talent
it took to actually drop my daughter off
and go to a spot
without having a nervous breakdown and I
did build a no no no no no
no no the courage to [ __ ] sleep in a
car and have people like Ralphie May
going his house and take a [ __ ] in the
shower
Ralphie to look down at me at the time
you know why because I was a man with a
dream and you weren't stopping the most
dangerous thing in the world is a man
with a [ __ ] dream bro that's on the
right track
not a man with a dream that's wow I got
a parking spot to head another I'm
talking about a man with a [ __ ] dream
that has that dream iron down the steps
on how he's gonna do that let me tell
you something I [ __ ] up I got a left
back in the seventh grade and I didn't
answer my mother was she was so dying
but if you don't think I planned this to
last ten years
you're [ __ ] crazy because I read
about you in my life every [ __ ] 90
days every 90 days I reevaluate my life
Lee because I know we're not gonna be
perfect every 90 days what aspects do
you look at what am i doing my life what
am i doing for me and what am i doing to
make some of the AUSA's world a little
bit [ __ ] better am i am i imposing my
influence on somebody who's having a
hard time you know I really try to help
out young comics as much as I do they're
not gonna get a [ __ ] handout you're
gonna work the same [ __ ] way I did
you know the time nobody here rides for
free nobody's gonna get a calling ball
come on let's go on the road don't work
like that [ __ ] I got to see the [ __ ]
math I got to see the work I got to see
the [ __ ] work because I will point
out ten comics about doing the [ __ ]
work every day I will point out a ten
young comics when I know the dead doing
the [ __ ] work everyday it's like when
I went on down the rivers podcast we
have a basketball mentality
you can't stop practicing because that
guy he's playing right now well you
shouldn't with your girlfriend on her
family jigging around that dude you're
gonna go up against in November for
first string and a UCLA he's practicing
right now
he's not [ __ ] jiggling and having a
good time he's gonna get oh right now
playing five on five in the [ __ ] rain
that's your mindset when you want to go
forward that somebody is
doing your job 20 [ __ ] times better
so you got no time to slack we got data
and that's what this book really is not
the Iceman you even said to me what's
this devil book you made me really
because you know what it when I tell you
here two weeks ago I said the best one
of the best books I ever read was
telemarketing in the eighties it really
it just taught me how to sell how to
narrow it down the sell the second book
that really got me here was that book by
Steven Pressfield
the warlord of the yarn of war what in
the [ __ ] it is it really got me here
because it got me to show me how much
time I've been wasting it pisses me off
yeah it's broken up in the section and
that first section like I had to I I had
to like he breaks it up beautifully it's
really easy to it's an easy read I just
like put the book down like every little
section and like I almost want to write
him an email and be like how do you
gotta get down well buddy you gotta get
your notebook and write what he's
explaining down so you never forget this
and every 90 days you couldn't read that
book every 60 days that books gonna keep
you honest you know I wish I would have
read that book when I was 28
oh I'd be on a yacht right now with my
state of mind I'd be on a yacht right
now maybe not a [ __ ] yet but I
wouldn't be renting a house I'd be
owning a house and I'd be owning a
[ __ ] insane and this is what I'm
telling people at the time well I told
you two months ago if I was pointing it
right now I wouldn't be [ __ ] around
I'd be thinking of my I was gonna make
my next [ __ ] Mele my first million
because it didn't get me is you're out
there for a pimp get harder and every
minute you waste up as a young adult
today oh because to be honest you guys
aren't prepared equity adequately you're
not prepared for what's about to happen
at Overlea you know Dom made a great
point we're both from Jersey here we
both have I came through the street I
don't know about nothing but you know
what I do know I get in the kind of all
you people listen to all these smart
guys I'm podcast may know about this
they don't know what uncle Joey knows
they don't know how to wake up in the
morning leave the [ __ ] house and come
back with money a lot of people don't
know how to do that I'll get my [ __ ]
white wife to come in here and tell you
guys how many times I left the house and
no matter what I brought home money if
you come to me and look me in the angle
Joe timing it on in 40 pay the phone
bill I feel bad for somebody do you
think you have you were speaking earlier
in the podcast around people realizing
resistance did you have resistance when
you were I guess movie coke with
resistance but everything I live with I
am resistance when you look my name in
the [ __ ] yellow pages its resistant
they should call me Joey resistance even
though you got so much done can you
imagine if I was an owner if I would
have known about resistance 20 years ago
I'm not trying to [ __ ] sell anybody
religion you're going to show you
rhetoric I'm just trying to make your
time [ __ ] more productive that's
Texas what you do in eight hours you
could possibly do it for because you're
talking on the phone Eugene he says in
the book babe listen you want me to lie
to you before I [ __ ] open up that lit
lift I gotta listen to music I got a
smoke a joint
I got a jerk-off I gotta get a piece of
cake that's all procrastination
that's all resistance if I and it's I
think what I feel powerful about
hourlies for me is that you're reading
in your own head because it's not like
it's a brilliant book but it's not like
it's not something that you should know
it's an easy read yeah easy read it
easily but that is from from the time I
was a kid I've been being told I was a
procrastinator and procrastinating is
bad and everyone everyone tells you all
this stuff but it just doesn't when
you're reading it to yourself and it's
your voice hearing it I don't know it
just drove me crazy like I had I got
called you like three times that's why
the when you write stuff down it goes
back to that when I tell you I kicked a
little lady in the tooth and ran away
with a purse we giggle hahaha when I
write that story down and I read that
story back it doesn't feel so good
anymore
so when you read something that's why I
had you recently cuz I wanted I want you
to talk about the podcast and I want you
to help other people that are going
through the same [ __ ] thing
well I put my pants on one leg at a time
just like you [ __ ] the movies
the span that's all [ __ ]
I'm a man first I was a loser a - loser
first before that so I know exactly what
everybody's going through that
struggling with Tahoe or they were
frustration frustration you have no idea
frustration is when you're at the store
killing people every night and you can't
get to Montreal and you can't get an
agent and you're booked in movies and
nobody wants to talk to you I had a
situation last week guys 25 [ __ ]
years and comedy I still get no respect
vieni crying about it no I go home I
took my dick between my legs and I try
to be a better version of myself and
that's all you could [ __ ] be starts
are you reading the [ __ ] book or not
we're going to do this kind of podcast
every two or three weeks about a certain
book or once a month and I hope you
enjoy these things I love reading and
I've learned a lot about reading and
have to [ __ ] I babble on about his life
experiences and have to share this [ __ ]
that I've read live learn some book
sometimes if I learn if I read something
from a book and it sounds a little kinky
I research it I'll go to one that walks
a [ __ ] guy you know dog I'm a [ __ ]
old-school dude I'm a Jewish Jesus
get him saying I'm friends with Jewish
Jesus Jewish Jesus question [ __ ]
everything you said we all have
different jobs when you're 67 you're
going to be a private detective I can
already you have look you do all this
research by yourself like you go
in-depth into some ways that no one else
would ever look at I can't believe we do
research into books I have to research
because how can I come in here and
repeat what I read in the [ __ ] book
because there's always one [ __ ] out
there with this internet world that'll
call you out because you said the word
wrong or whatever you know so before
when I read these things if I read any
book if there's a part of a book that
like one legend when I read that that
book about Led Zeppelin and they said
they stuff a shark up a chick [ __ ] in
Seattle I did research for a week you
know just before you know when I heard
that
that John Lennon had written Fame and
then he wrote many in the Jets were out
in John I did the research for a [ __ ]
week I don't want to tell somebody and
then look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know saying yeah let me give a shout out
to my sponsors I'll get you out of here
first off blue apron let me explain
something to you
we tell them when they deliver the food
how nice is it it's amazing they they
deliver literally everything you need to
make all these amazing meals it's all in
one box
they have it they have a little
knick-knack set up like all your little
sauces and oils and then they have all
the vegetables and fruit and all your
meat and there's no waste all right and
for less than $10 per meal per person
blue apron delivers seasonal recipes
along with proportion ingredients to
make delicious home-cooked meals choose
from a variety of new recipes each week
or let blue aprons culinary team
surprise you recipes are not repeated
within a year so you'll never get bored
customize your recipes each week based
on your preferences blue apron at
several delivery options so you can
choose what fits your needs and there's
no weekly commitment so you can only get
the deliveries when you want them each
meal comes with a step-by-step easy to
follow recipe cards and pre-portioned
ingredients that can be prepared in 40
minutes or less
for example this weekend you got your
tackle shiitake mushroom burgers with
miso mayonnaise you got seared chicken
with French lentils on the arugula feta
you got a kale white cheddar quesadilla
with a fried egg are you kidding me or
what get the party started now check out
this week's menu and get three feet
three first three meals free with free
shipping when you go to blue apron com
slash Joey that's blue aprons freshness
guaranteed promises that every
ingredient in your delivery arrives
ready to cook or they'll make it right
you'll love how it feels you'll love how
it tastes and you'll love to create
incredible home-cooked meals with blue
apron so don't wait that's blue apron
dot-com slash Joey and get your first
three meals free blue apron dot-com
slash Joey blue apron a better way to
cook and I'm gonna give you free
shipping also what do you think of that
MVM tea
watch when you go out people always
idiot you look at a sharp it's beautiful
matches your shirt they come in
different colors let me tell you
something MB MD is a company that
started by two Broke college kids that
one of the West Irish watches but
couldn't afford them like anybody else
so they started their own watch company
alright they started just like us snakes
going through podcast they did it online
they built a following they went to a
YouTube radio etc movement watches start
at $95 at a department store you're
looking at 400 to 500 bucks movements
figured out that by selling online they
were able to cut out the middleman and
the retail markup providing the best
possible price classic design quality
construction and style minimalism over a
hundred million watches so let me tell
you something Father's Day is coming if
you're out right here get 15% off today
with free shipping and free returns by
going MB MT watches calm / Church this
watch has a really nice clean design
seriously leaves them getting
compliments ever since you put it on now
is the time to step up your watch game
so 2 MB MT watches dot-com / church join
the movement
I want to thank MB MT I want to thank
blue apron and as usual my Mane's orbs
all right on it supplying the most clean
supplements out there from the shrimp
export to the to the hem force protein
to the Alpha brand 100% guarantee go to
Alan calm right now press in charge and
get 10% off delivered right the house
will see you [ __ ] in two days
get the party started stay black uncle
Joey loves you